hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well was there a name
written by law and that's a good
question enhance because you know the
picture that we put out so far you got a
guy let's say you know put aside the
question of whether guys this or now
let's just say we're accepting Thomas's
views there is a God he's the sort of
God that Christians Jews Muslims
describe him as you've all created
everything oh nothing
structures everything cares about the
the creation that it's not sort of a
capricious God made things just to break
them or anything he actually cares about
what's going on and he gave human beings
reason and certain inclination so that
they could figure things out well then
why would you need something else why
would the natural law be enough he says
well the natural law isn't enough for a
couple of reasons so he says besides the
natural and human law it was necessary
for the directing of human conduct
you have a divine one and this for four
reasons
what are the reasons well he says first
it's by the water that human beings are
directed how to perform a proper acts
and view of their their last step so
let's say we you know put that in a more
contemporary language in order to figure
out what's going to make it truly happy
you know you have to do what's what's
right you have to actually follow you
know what's going to satisfy your your
inclinations and attain here your hands
now remember back to last class as the
sort of creatures of the art of Comus is
our last end as our final that is what's
going to make us fully happy something
in the world Thomas
yeah yeah so then II created good that
could be part of happiness but it's not
going to be the whole thing the natural
law will help us to attain happiness
here you know for instance the natural
wobble tell us you can get along with
other people if you're not actually
getting along with other people you're
probably not going to be very happy
right
even of happiness where you can just
consistent pleasure you're probably not
going to join up on pleasure just people
are gonna want to take it away because
you're irritated right so the natural
law will help you out with some things
but it won't actually direct you to the
ultimate so a divine law is needed for
that so that's one of these
the second reason he says the
uncertainty of human judgement
especially on contingent in particular
manners as we get away from the more
general to the warm or particular we can
go wrong a lot easier and it's not just
because you know we're fallible human
beings or yes because particularly
things are actually hard to judge it's
really easy to and think about math
classes right all of you remember having
problems and learning how to do certain
things what were the kind of problems
that always bothered well not
necessarily in all of you but most of
you most lower the word over the
problems that you didn't like to do oh
really
well that was one that deposited most I
all sorts of irrational things myself
like I didn't like
you know I the negative answer that was
kind of kind of what people complain
about myself and we're gonna teach tests
was it word problems
yeah why do people try to work problems
problems are sometimes ambiguous are
they like you something can be
interpreted in multiple ways
I suppose fractions of the long division
you know it's possible to get things
wrong and that's sort of one of these
ones but it's not quite the same thing
as things being ambiguous if your
teacher writes word problems badly you
can't figure out how to solve
okay and there's certain situations when
we get away from the very general we
start getting into the nitty-gritty
Thomas has a great example a little bit
later on question 94 he's talking about
giving back something in return
this is a classic problem in general if
somebody gives something to you and says
hold on to this for me when they ask you
for it you should give it back right
like a weapon for example what do they
say I'm going to need my gun back
because I want to go in and shoot up
that workplace should you give up now
you know you know this year you're sort
of going against the general rule that
you always want to return what's what's
given to you right so now your
inclinations right now it would be the
wrong thing to do why because there are
certain particulars
you have to be able to look at those
particulars so human want some tech
screws it up doesn't it would be helpful
on certain matters particularly very
murky matters to have some divine hope
that they have some sort of statement
from above okay here's what we need to
do with us or the situation like to
think about Thomas doesn't use this
exact here but this is a great example
should you forgive people who harm you
one of the distinctive things that you
find the end Christian thought is this
emphasis on forgiveness none of your
religion preaches that - by the way or
work reaches it to the same extent and
not every moral theory would necessarily
you know if your utilitarian there could
be some good purpose behind forgiveness
you know it could serve something
gentlemen happiness thing but not
necessarily maybe it's better than you
know people screw up you come down hard
on them and if they cross you maybe it's
better than you you know cause them some
pain so that you know we turn the more
pleasure later well you know the divine
law stressed forget it even by the way
that's not something you need to
Christianity if you look at the Jewish
Scriptures you know before the New
Testament you will find injunctions to
forgive
but less of an emphasis how would we
know that that's really something that
the natural law requires of us if
something didn't come along to clarify
that for us that's one of the purposes
of the defining law to give a little bit
of clarification on these these
particulars he says here's the third one
human beings can make laws in those
matters of which were competent to judge
now what do we actually get to see about
another person why is it that you might
not know what people as well as that you
think you do you might be surprised by
their good behavior they're like tell
what they're thinking and what they
really feel the pen yeah in their mind
yeah Thomas puts it in terms of you
can't know another person's heart but
who can forget it is this sort of
theological schema God
so Thomas talks about interior
dispositions in addition to take actions
it says
human beings are not competent to judge
of interior movements that are hidden
but only an exterior acts which appear
we you know we get to see the outsides
of other people and you can actually go
start to infer some things about that
all right if somebody screws you over
each time that you you deal with them or
you get
conversation with them and every time
you're in a conversation they try to
one-up you you can figure out after a
while that you don't want to hang out
with that person and that there's
something wrong inside of that right
it's not just a bunch of exterior ask
but do you really know what's going on
with them you can't like open up their
head look inside see what's that can you
can't peer into their soul so the divine
law he says the human laws can only look
at exterior things did you follow a
large they can even you know if
somebody's dumb enough to say I didn't
follow the millat as I hate the law they
can you know job some interior things
then but for the most part they can't so
the divine law comes along and the
divine law like he says can tell us
about what we need to do in order to
have virtually because it knows human
beings a bit better than these in part
because it's coming through from God in
a more direct way than the natural law
which is built into our engagement with
use reason terms so again you think
about the example of forgiveness
Aristotle said you should get angry at
sometimes right any I need to forgive
some people but if you actually read
their song carefully they'll say there's
a lot of cases we shouldn't forget as a
matter of fact you're doing the right
thing by not forgiving bad people
what does Christianity teach
yeah we should even pray for your
enemies now that's a weird thing to say
you should pray for people who paint you
you should like wish them well even
knowing that they're probably it'll
remain complete bastards you know and
still try to get you and all that means
is it's pretty tough stuff to hear ISM
you think that the analog would tell you
that would you you know sitting by
yourself at some determinate situation
using the reason that you've been given
to come to the conclusion that yeah that
person is mean to me but instead of
being mean to them which is one one one
of my inclinations would be and natural
information right meeting you don't you
wanna be mean to them I know I do the
divine one comes along and says you
should forgive and not only she to do it
this time you should do it at other
times because that's going to build up a
kind of habit within you that will make
you a happier person and a better person
yeah it may not even changes another
person too
they may continue to do what they do
that's not really your and your concern
the divine level come along and help you
toward certain things and virtues that
natural love by itself wouldn't get you
to the fourth one it says less human
want cannot punish it forbid all evil
deeds why not well when you try to do
away with all the evils you also end up
doing away with a lot of good human was
kind of a blunt instrument it's
difficult to write a lot as well so that
that they actually attack what's wrong
what's bad and not also screw some some
things up that are good but there are
plenty of things that the divine evolved
over time did tell people that we were
wrong that they didn't seem to beginning
and because the Bible you know came to
them
people were actually following that they
realized it wasn't it wasn't good I'll
give you an example actually I'll say
handsome that you may find manner funny
he wrote a king of Ireland while he was
Archbishop of Canterbury please he's a
bishop he's in charge of you know
teaching so he writes this guy because
things we're taught and he tells them
hey I've heard about something that's
going on over there and you shouldn't be
doing it I know it's a lot of fun for
you but I don't think that you should be
doing it and you're the king so you
should probably make sure that this
isn't happening what he's complaining
about I never thought this was engine
historically the case or not he says you
guys are swapping your wires you're
trading them out with each other just
like you people getting off one horse
and onto another and that's not right
you know and then he says to hear the
divine law would come in I mean the
natural law would tell you that's not a
good idea but sometimes we don't get the
natural law he tells them you know if
you want to know you're not supposed to
do that
you can either read the scriptures or
have somebody else read them to you and
that's how he talks to this this King
that would be an example of something
where the divine law has been very clear
about look this just can't go this is
something that's bad for you it's bad
for them it's bad for your subjects you
didn't seem to get it with the natural
laws of matter of fact your human law
that you're enacting over there and
Ireland seems to say this is a okay so
none of divine
come in and clarify things so Thomas
does think that there is a need for a
divided along one thing I do want to
point out right before we finish up at
this part these are going to these are
going to be saying more or less the same
thing this is going to be a bit more
specific in certain things and the
natural walk and get murky for us
because we often tend to be you know
disorder desires sort of like a support
system for the natural is primarily
natural because if you're functioning
well the things that are being talked
about like you know think about the 10
commandments
whatever what are some of the types of
matters that have to do with what you
ought to do with other people yeah I
don't don't murder anybody
right well you you know if you didn't
get if like your things weren't working
for you right
or your society said tell anybody you
like so long as they don't we have you
know then he would be good to have the
Bible to come along and say you know
don't kill anybody don't murder people
but you could actually just consult to
be actual water figure that out couldn't
you if you're being honest with yourself
your conscience could convict you even
if you didn't have some sort of
religious authority because they're
telling the same thing what was another
yeah and you know adultery how would we
sort of Rican see that now don't you
know don't cheat in relationships don't
you seduce anybody else over their
relationship and again do you need the
Bible to actually tell you that I mean
if you do pretty hard up if that's the
only reason why you're not going out and
sleeping with other people spouses then
you really do need the divine laws but
you know if you think about it and you
think boy this is not a smart thing to
do this is actually hurting people this
is damaging the relationships is not
good for me over time you would be using
the natural law you could figure that
out on your own Thomas thanks let's
think about that one governments don't
steal again if things were screwed up
for you and you know somebody came up to
us look it says here in the Bible don't
steal and it doesn't say it here it says
there's a whole bunch of other places
too and that kept you from stealing
that'd be good right but could you
figure that out on your own I think you
probably could and Thomas I see but to
because that's part of the natural law
as well